so
[Music]
on tv
on radio and on your smartphone this is
talk tv
[Music]
[Music]
good evening i'm pierce morgan
uncensored tonight the interviews that
the whole world's been talking about
gypsy king tyson fury the queen of rock
sharon osbourne and of course president
donald trump
now as you may have heard i had a rather
lively encounter with the most famous
and divisive man in the world present
company accepted it was an explosive
interview covering everything from the
future of the royal family to what
donald trump told vladimir putin about
invading ukraine but first the question
seemingly on everyone's lips when i said
i was doing donald trump again is he
going to run for president in 2024
well you know for reasons of campaign
finance and everything i'm not allowed
to say but let me just say this i think
a lot of people are going to be very
happy
so you want me
i love our country our country is going
to hell i think a lot of people are
going to be very happy are you going to
run i'm not going to say that but i
think people are going to be happy you
might even be happy if it's you against
joe biden if you win the republican
nomination again and he runs again would
you beat him
i believe right now anybody i think you
could beat him right now our country is
a mess our country has never been so
disrespected our borders have never been
so open we've never had in 44 years
inflation like we have it you run again
and you win
which could well happen i think whoever
the republican candidate
right now it looks like the democrats
are going to get shellacked in the
midterms it's quite likely whoever is a
republican nominee
will end up being president it could be
you again and for as many people who
think that's a great idea you'll know
there are lots of people who think that
would be a total nightmare far less
far less i think so yeah i think far
less i think people are very angry at
this country they're very angry at our
leadership
they wish they had their vote to do
again
we didn't need their vote because again
we won the election by a tremendous
margin we won the election actually very
easily
one of the other questions about
potentially running again is you've been
in that pressure cauldron of the white
house with your family they've all come
under huge attack
your children your wife melania
would you be happy to put them back in
there would they be happy to be back in
there well i won't get into that but i
will tell you they all love the country
and we did a great job it's been a
tumultuous time for the world for the
country
there is a chance that you're going to
be running quite clearly you've made
that clear in this interview i don't
think i've made it clear
i think that's it but i think people are
going to be very happy i don't know
there'll be people unhappy but i think
people are going to be very happy so
those who are
who don't like you
there's people out there that don't like
you i know you said recently that you
were very popular and i think he said he
was the most honest man in the world
i'm a very honest man was that true
yeah i think i'm a very honest man so
those who don't like you much more
honest than you actually really yeah i'm
pretty honest because i don't think
you're real right yeah i think i'm a
much more honest person in most ways and
most recently why am i not real but
we're not going to get into that let's
finish up the interview go ahead
go ahead go ahead next question was this
what message do you have to people who
can't think of anything worse than you
running again
and will be distressed about it would
you come back with all the experience
you've had
of being president would you come back a
different person would you do things a
bit differently so i like this question
in a certain way because i came in and i
was attacked from day one
unfairly russia russia russia was a hoax
the impeachment hoax number one number
two it was all a big hoax the mueller
report
and i had to fight back and i had to
fight back strongly and if i didn't
fight back strongly i wouldn't have
survived and i say it and i say it loud
i had two jobs to do
run the country really well and the
second was to survive
no other president went through this
fake stuff i only ask you when we did
celebrity apprentice together
which i've really enjoyed and it was
good yeah yeah yeah
when i did that with you i saw a very
different donald trump in the boardrooms
for those hours every night
you were you know you weren't as
aggressive and confrontational except i
wasn't under siege with phony with phony
russian russia
by the way
the russian collusion thing was
ridiculous no no and many others right
but my point is if you've got a chance
again
would we see more of that donald trump
do you think
depends on how you're greeted
but if you greet it unfairly you have to
be tough and you have to fight i would
like that i would much prefer that but
it depends on how you agreed it but
i would do
when i say this our country's in trouble
something has to happen and if it
doesn't happen and if we don't have
smart leadership you're going to end up
with no world the world is going to be
blown to pieces we have stupid people
now running our country the world is
going to be blown to pieces
donald trump has often lavished praise
on the queen nothing's changed in his
admiration for her majesty since he left
office but he does have rather different
opinions about prince andrew on the
future of the monarchy and the future of
harry and megan
met the queen
it was supposed to be for 20 minutes i
saw you just after you saw it right it
was supposed to be just a quick meeting
and it was beautiful the pompid ceremony
nobody does it like the english i don't
know what it is but nobody does it like
we have a certain you know but i met her
and it turned out to be more than an
hour substantially
because she liked me and i liked her and
she's let it be known she liked me and i
let it be honest i've had other members
of the royal family tell me they enjoyed
your company we had a great time and
then they honored the united states but
they honored me that night which is
really the honor of the country and it
was at the top level and i sat next to
her we talked the whole night
and somebody said
we've never seen her smile so much we
had a great time she was laughing and
smiling they said they've never seen her
have such a good time at a state dinner
you know normally they're a little
boring okay this wasn't boring so
i have a lot of respect for the queen
she's incredible she loves her country i
think she's incredible look at her she's
been queen for what 70 years or
something and
she's never made a mistake even when the
guy broke into a room
sits him down talks to him quietly does
what everything she's done now some of
the kids it's you know they make a
little mistake every once in a while
sometimes a big one what did you make of
this prince andrews well it was a
terrible thing it was a you know
terrible thing i think terrible for a
lot of people but but
the queen i don't know has she ever even
made a mistake
she's an incredible woman i'm not a fan
of megan yeah i'm not a fan and i wasn't
right from the beginning what did you
make and i think
i think poor harry is being led around
by his nose
and i think he's an embarrassment you
know here's my issue with it i think
that
they've quit the country they quit royal
duty they're living in luxury in
california
they want to use their royal titles to
exploit them for massive financial gain
without any of the duty that comes with
the royal titles i don't think you can
have your royal cake and eat it that's
my argument about it so i want to know
what's going to happen when harry
decides he's had enough of being boss
around or maybe when she decides that
she likes some other guy better i want
to know what's going to happen
when it ends
okay do you think it's going to end i do
i've been a very good predictor as you
know i predicted almost everything it'll
end and it'll end bad and i wonder if
harry's going to go back on his hands
and knees back into
the beautiful city of london and say
please you know i think harry has been
led down a path i found it when i heard
he wasn't going to prince phillips
memorial terrible
i found that i couldn't believe that
yeah
he would not go to that he was at the
super bowl he was a texas rodeo but he
couldn't find time to go on a plane i
think that was
a terrible thing many terrible things
that might have been
as you mentioned it that might have been
the worst of all
because he was you know like her he was
a tough cookie too i remember years ago
prince philip came to
new york and we were in the plaza hotel
and there were many people wanting to
meet him
and we were all taking a picture with
him many people and the photographers
said i'll never forget this he was tough
the photographer said please move back
there were like 30 of us and he said no
you moved back
and that was simple i said that's pretty
good you know this guy's tough but i'll
never forget that i don't mean that in a
derogatory i mean good way yeah instead
of having this whole group of people
moving back plenty of room the
photographer and he immediately moved
back i said wow
i mean
the queen had to be pretty tough because
i think she was he was tough when he
died i think it was a devastating moment
for the queen i think they had a great
relationship but he was a strong guy i
never forgot a little moment right he
just said no you moved back
and he didn't say it in a nice way
because the photographer was pushing
everybody around a little bit foolishly
but um
i thought it was terrible when he didn't
go to the funeral of prince philip yeah
i think i think the harry
situation has
is going to unfold in a much different
way
if you were the queen is it at the stage
now would you remove their royal title i
would i take i
the only thing i disagree with the queen
on probably one of the only things ever
is that i think she should have said if
that's your choice fine but you no
longer have titles you no longer and
frankly
don't come around
you just because her loyalty is to the
country she said that many times her
loyalty is to the country
and i think that he has been so
disrespectful to the country
and it's a great country
i own a lot of things there i own a
place called turnberg and in aberdeen i
own and i mean we have aberdeen is
beautiful the oil capital of europe
and i own things there and i love that
country it's it's incredible it's
scotland i love i love turnberry i love
what i did there i built things here
and i respect great one of the best in
the world and i will tell you um
she is she is more passionate about
her role and and the country it's going
to be very interesting
someday she won't be there right it'll
be very interesting what happens and i
know charles pretty well
and i think and camilla i think you sat
with me i do and and i'll tell you what
uh she was on my right the queen was on
my left
and i said
queen
i really have to talk to camilla for a
little while too you know no we we
couldn't break apart and i talked to
camilla and camilla was so nice
you know different than i thought she
was funny she was smart quick
i really liked she was great i like her
too and
uh i like charles i mean he's serious do
you think they'll make a good king and
queen when that time comes i hope so i
think it's it's a it's going to be
tricky
he's going to have to be yeah and it's
going to be tricky because they are
truly replacing you talking about a
legendary this woman
she's got to have the all-time record
she's the greatest i mean in your
lifetime is she the greatest of all the
leaders of any kind well so my mother
was born in scotland and i remember as a
little boy
anything where the queen was on anything
at all where
and it was the pomp and ceremony but my
mother had tremendous
love and respect
for the young queen at that time he
would have been a kid when she got
coronated right i was mid-50s but but my
mother wouldn't leave the screen
and she'd go back to scotland almost
every year you know she loved scotland
she loved but she loved the queen
and
so does everybody and for this person to
come along and
criticize the queen
it's just
you just can't do that so it'll be
interesting to see how it all works out
harry is whipped do you know the
expression i'm familiar with i won't use
the full expression but harry is whipped
like no person i think i've ever seen
the most wicked man in the world this is
i don't know that's going to be a big
one but he is he is a whipped man yeah
uncensored next sharon was born on her
year in the eye of the cancer culture
storm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well tonight we introduce cancelled
corner i'll regularly invite someone
onto my show who's been silenced or
become a victim of cancelled culture and
i will formally uncancel them and
restore them back to a civilized
democratic society tonight my guess is
sharon osbourne now her career suddenly
ended because she had the audacity to
defend my right to have an opinion over
the markle debacle on her u.s panel show
the talk
here's what
happened i have
felt that pierce was racist in his
stance against meghan markle and the
last time he was on this show i said as
much if he doesn't pierce doesn't like
someone and they happen to be
black
does that make him a racist
no no
that's a no no right
so why can't it be he just doesn't like
her why does it have to be racist
well sharon's here with me now i want to
start with this tweet because it was a
tweet that really ignited the firestorm
you just said this as this markle
debacle went down in the uk you tweeted
this piece morgan i'm with you i stand
by you people forget that you're paid
for your opinion and that you're just
speaking your truth
what's incredible about that is you
don't actually agree with my opinion i
mean you might well have done you didn't
say
i agree with what he's saying
you just said
he's entitled to an opinion and for that
you end up losing your job yeah because
my my whole point was is that you are a
journalist and a celebrity so therefore
you're paid to give your opinion the
same as i was paid to give my opinion
that's why we're there and
and freedom of speech
when it was all going down on the talk
in cbs
did you imagine in your wildest
nightmare that within days you would
have been fired from a show you've been
over 10 years
i was actually in my 11th year
and the situation
i never thought
in my wildest dreams that my career
after 50 years would have ended that way
i mean what did did i want my legacy to
be i was fired because i was accused of
being a racist what was so disingenuous
was their initial attack from sharon
underwood your co-presenter who i know
i've been on the talk many times with
you and with cheryl always very friendly
but that day the mood changed and it
looked like she was deliberately coming
for you
for in her eyes endorsing a racist me
and when you said well what's he said
that's racist she couldn't tell you and
eventually she explained my refusal to
believe meghan markle
basically made me a racist oh yes that
was the whole that was the whole setup
that you were a racist because you had
an opinion on somebody that was of mixed
race
i've never known you have a racist bone
in your body i would like to think
you've never felt that in me never we
are not racist people no we never judge
people because of their skin color i've
certainly never written anything about
meghan markle because of her mixed race
religion
you and i could give
you know that that's not the way we run
our lives
when you got fired
you get turfed out by the cancel culture
mob twitter is a blaze they're joyful
they're gleeful they've got rid of you
they've they've got you out of that job
they've had you fired
for
having an opinion what was going through
your mind when when the first few days
after that it was um
listen i don't scare easily you know
that but
some of the
comments that were coming through on my
social media were so horrific about
cutting my throat my husband even the
dogs they wanted to kill my dogs and
then they started on aussie on his site
and then my kids and i just thought this
this is just insanity i had the same
thing i went back to cbs and i said you
not only can i not earn a living
but now i have to have 24 hours security
because of you and they go like
so what
so your lives were being put under
threat by these menacing people on
social media and you don't know who's
real and who's not
also your career just basically
ended i mean no one would touch you you
were toxic
you were driven out in a race storm
therefore you were untouchable it
it was
i mean literally
untouchable it was from
you know everyday stuff comes in when
you do this that and you know charity
stuff and everything the phone never
rang
that was it you are untouchable so when
people say council culture doesn't exist
you live through it and you live through
it because of me
and i thought what happened to me was
bad now what happened to you to me was
utterly shameful
but cancelled culture is real isn't it
you become
this person that no one will want to
employ because suddenly you're that
person oh absolutely you are untouchable
you are an untouchable and what makes me
so mad is i'm in a blessed situation
that no matter what ever happens to my
career my husband will always take care
of me but what happens to a person
that you know
say i didn't have a husband and i had
kids to bring up right what happens to
people like that that are cancelled or
fired because they've said use the wrong
term
or something's taken out of context and
they're fired
to the average person what happens to
that person have you ever spoken again
to cheryl underwood who was your
co-presenter on i um sent her
three texts of apologies and she never
got back and then she went on to um
national tv and said that i hadn't
apologized so what i did was i
actually on my social media printed the
text and then she said well that's not
an apology because uh it wasn't i wanted
a in a phone call and she never called
me and let me just hold one moment what
are you apologizing for i thought you
had nothing to apologize for
what i'm also interested in is what
happened to you later because
your life i mean
it didn't completely fall apart because
you had your family but it was
incredibly tough for you it was tough
for me and it did affect me um mentally
i i it honestly did because after
everything that i'd felt all my dreams i
had achieved everything that i'd wanted
to do i had achieved and did i want my
legacy for my family to be oh well your
nana was on television but everybody
said she was racist so she never went on
television again and that kind of
me up what did that do to you it kept me
up i couldn't i must have cried for
three months
never stop crying and my friends um
sarah gilbert who used to you know
right she she was the one that came up
with the idea for the show and was on it
and she said you need help you've got to
go somewhere and she recommended
somewhere and then i was doing therapy
and ketamine treatment
did you get suicidal at any stage
not suicidal because i didn't want to
give
cbs the satisfaction
i'm so glad that we're able to sit here
now talking about this i'm going to come
to why you're here and what you're going
to do next in a moment
you're going to be
doing what you do best talking about
news and current affairs and stuff in
the in the papers and so on i've got to
ask you about the trump interview he's
clearly hinting in my interview that he
may run again he's still popular in
america very popular and with joe biden
being such a disaster at the moment you
could see a situation where trump gets
re-elected would that be a good thing do
you think for america
no i don't think it would be a good
thing and the thing that frightens me is
there is nobody
nobody that you could think of that
would make a great president so the
competition is non-existent we are both
monarchists we love the world family how
damaging is this drip drip drip behavior
of megan and harry running a kind of
rival
royal family without any of the need for
the duty that goes with that but with
all the money that comes their way from
fleecing the royal title it's just
tragic that you can
go and try and
ruin a monarchy and
you know what we all grew up with loving
adoring respecting and then every time
you open your mouth it's about your
family and the other thing i think that
nobody's ever said is their children
their beautiful children have no family
they don't speak to megan's family
they don't speak to the royal family
these children are going to grow their
grandfather no grandparents my
grandfather it's almost live 70 miles
away
there's no grandfather there's no aunts
there's no family so just think of your
children when they when you're talking
about cousins and aunts i don't think
about anything about themselves and and
the bottom line
i'm about to do something special
i'm about to formally uncancel you
because you're back now at talk tv
thanks to the same network with me well
i was delighted to help be part of
getting you back here how important is
it to you to be back on television doing
what you do best on a show called the
talk it's very important to me it's
something that i love
and i just again you know didn't want it
to end my career in such an ugly way and
how is aussie my great man is just one
of my favorite people in the world been
through the health wars a bit how's he
doing he's doing okay he is he sends you
his love
and he's really looking forward he's got
one more operation left to to do and
then he he's dying to come back home
well sending my very best and i'm now
going to have the great honor sean
osborne of officially uncounseling you
to the world and restoring you to your
rightful place as the queen of the talk
let it roll
oh
we need to confess we need some music to
celebrate what about this
[Music]
it's aussie
it's changes
the song is very appropriate it couldn't
be better right
it's time for change welcome back
lovely to see you
sharon osbourne
i'm cancelled
i love it i love it
[Music]
great to see sharon smiling again well
uncensored next he's one of america's
most influential cable news hosts i'll
be speaking live to fox news's tucker
class
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk tv
[Music]
it's one of the most influential
conservative voices in america a fiery
and opinionated tv news host who's never
far from the headlines fox news
firebrand tucker carson gave me his
verdict on that emotional sharon osborne
interview
so you're not allowed to express
skepticism about the public statements
of one of the most powerful people in
the world and sharon osborne is not
allowed to affirm your right to express
that skepticism and both of you get
fired for it so that's commentary on the
society that allows that to happen i
mean that's the definition of tyranny of
societal collapse like that's insane
that's the kind of thing that if it
happened in north korea we'd be like
well that's you know that's the society
we need to oppose
and this is happening in two of the free
societies in the world so um yeah i
don't think we're being hysterical when
we say
this is the main threat that all of us
face and what is extraordinary to me is
they they profess to be liberals these
sort of ultra woke council culture mob
people uh basically liberal about i mean
liberalism to me means that you you know
you believe in in democracy you believe
in free speech you believe in the fair
exchange of views you tolerate other
people's opinions they don't do any of
those things they behave it ironically
they behave like the very fascists they
claim to hate most
well of course and i i always think of
myself as a liberal i believe
fully and completely in free speech in
freedom of conscience
i am horrified by violence even
state-sponsored violence
i even like organic peanut butter so
to have these people telling me
that we should throw anyone who
disagrees with them out of work or into
prison have them call themselves liberal
talk about a perversion of the word
it's preposterous now i'm sure it hasn't
escaped you'll notice i interviewed
president uh trump uh ex-president trump
i guess um i want to play you a clip and
what do you say when i asked him the big
question everyone's sort of toying with
is he going to run again listen to what
he said
so here's the big question for you which
everybody wants to know the latest poll
says if the 2024 election was held
tomorrow you would beat joe biden by six
points and kamala harris by 11 points in
other words you would be re-elected
president of the united states so are
you going to run again well you know for
reasons of campaign finance and
everything i'm not allowed to say but
let me just say this i think a lot of
people are going to be very happy
i love our country our country is going
to hell i think a lot of people are
going to be very happy you're going to
run i'm not going to say that but i
think people are going to be happy you
might even be happy
what did you make of that tucker do you
think he's going to run again and i
suppose i got to ask you would you like
him to run again is it healthy for
america for the republican party how do
you see the way things are shaping up
here
what's healthy is for america or any
country great britain to be able to
choose its own leaders when the public
gets to decide by majority vote so i'm
just for democracy period i would say in
the case of trump i think he does love
america i think he sincerely believes
the election was stolen from him i don't
think he's just saying that he really
thinks that whether you agree with him
or not
whether you think he should be allowed
to say that or not he really does
believe that um and i think he would
like to be vindicated in that belief and
maybe running again would be one way to
do it i personally and he hasn't said
this to me
you know i'm not an advisor to trump
hardly but i i actually don't think he
wants to be president again that's my
view you know he's got a happy life um
he
affects you know american politics a lot
in his endorsements and i think
all things being equal he'd rather do
that and there are other people who
would like to run and you know i i
personally don't think he's going to run
again i'm basing that on
no evidence whatsoever just a gut
feeling um and i'm i'm often wrong i
could be wrong again but that's that's
my view now you talk about other people
who may be considering running you
yesterday got put in the frame because
you apparently going to go and speak in
iowa always a sign that potentially
someone may be thinking of a career
outside cable news you are uniquely
popular now with the conservative base
let me ask you directly tucker carlson
do you have a plan to run for president
our show is popular
for the moment i've had a lot of shows
like you have sometimes they're popular
sometimes they're not
you know i've been fired for low ratings
so i've seen both sides of that um
and but that doesn't mean you know i've
never been in politics i've never been
elected you know room mother
um i'm not sure i have political skills
i will give a speech to anybody anytime
i'm really interested in what the
republican party becomes because it is
the alternative to what we're seeing now
the neoliberalism of joe biden which i
don't think works i don't think is
popular and so i'm interested in seeing
the people who want to replace him
and some of them seem legitimate others
seem you know loathsome to be totally
honest so you know i
that's the reason i'm going is i want to
see these people and i want to talk to
them and i want to talk about them
now who better to throw some light on
the thorny issue of trans women in sport
than olympic gold medalist caitlyn
jenner i'll give you the most famous
trans woman in the world
we have to change the rules
we have to do a better job because the
bottom line is
we have to keep it fair
and i don't want to ruin women's sports
or discourage women from getting into
sports because they think oh my gosh i'm
gonna have to compete against a bunch of
guys i mean i totally agree it's not
fair i totally agree kaitlyn but what i
would also say is i don't want to expose
trans people to mockery which is now
going on with this debate because it
looks so ridiculous that you see leah
thomas just dominating women's sport and
i think that trans people who don't want
to be part of any big angry debate about
this want to go about their lives in
peace and quiet and get on with it i
think they're being affected adversely
by this debate and it seems to me
nobody's prepared to put the herd over
the parapet and go look this is clearly
unfair and wrong
here's how we're going to change things
if you were in charge of changing things
to make it fair what is the answer
should trans women athletes for example
compete against men should trans
athletes have their own category now of
competition given there are more and
more trans athletes what's the
answer well here's pierce here's here's
the problem we have here this is a very
very
complicated issue just like being trans
is very complicated
um it's very it's there's no right
there's no right answer here pierce um
if you just say
you know no trans athletes um you know
in sports
uh well what about female to male
they're trans that's 49 of the
population 51 percent are male to female
um if we
what happens to the young
uh trans uh
athletes who transitioned some of them
when they're five six seven years old
they take hormone blockers and they grow
up as little girls their whole life they
have no advantage whatsoever you know
over the other girls
and what do we do there so it almost has
to be treated on an individual basis but
i think the first thing we have to do is
we
we have to make the qualifying for a
trans athlete a little bit more
difficult for them to be able to compete
because i think the number one thing we
have to do is protect
women's sports i mean you've never seen
cases
well you never see you you mentioned
there people who transition from female
to male but you never see any issue
there on the sporting side because they
never have an unfair advantage you know
the key point really about i guess trans
women athletes is they have an unfair
natural biological advantage that's the
number of the problem
if they went through male puberty yeah
you're absolutely right
i went through male puberty okay
i mean i don't even play
i mean i play a lot of golf yeah and at
our club i mean i play with the women a
lot by the way
appears the women a lot more fun to play
with than the men but the conversation's
much better but they always ask you know
hey we've got a tournament coming up
yeah we've got a tournament coming up
you want to play with us
and you know when i'm there i say oh
that would be fun but then i never show
up
why because it's just honestly it's i
don't i would never want to take a
trophy away from one of the other i love
the ladies at our club they're wonderful
i wouldn't want to take i can out drive
them by a hundred yards yeah exactly you
know and yeah
yeah and it's just my arms are longer
i'm six one
um what i got left over is more than
what most people ever had
and
so i it just wouldn't be fair okay so
i don't play in that i'll be honest
you know honestly leah thomas is one of
the
toughest one of the hardest uh
one of the worst things that happened to
the trans community yeah i agree because
it's such
bad publicity yeah i've met so many
wonderful trans people doing wonderful
things living their life authentically i
hope leah thomas it's over for her now
because she's out of out of college and
i just hope she has a wonderful life
being trans is not easy
um and i hope she enjoys the rest of her
life and has a good life you know okay
really i completely what leah did is we
need to look at the rules
coming up the world heavyweight champion
of the world tyson fury undefeated and
now uncensored
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now tyson the gypsy king fury the
undefeated wbc heavyweight champion
speaking exclusively to me just days
after his knockout victory over dillian
white at wembley another world exclusive
interview but piers morgan uncensored
you've got to keep moving forward in a
positive manner and never let anybody
anybody tell you you can't do something
because there's so many dream crushers
out there and naysayers and they all
want you to see you on the floor but
you've got to keep getting back up and
disappointing them piss that's what you
keep doing when you heard tyson sharon
osborne telling her story could you
believe really what happened to her what
do you make of this canceled culture
where for having an opinion or even
saying someone's allowed an opinion you
get your life ruined and you get fired
i think the world has gone mad peace you
can't there's only a freedom of speech
until it upsets somebody and it doesn't
exist anymore
um and like you said in the interview
this is what you guys get paid to do of
your opinion so if your opinion's no
good then what's the point you know it's
it's one of them it's uh the world's
gone crazy and it's a shame that people
like yourself and like sharon and even
me
we can't say stuff we're gonna offend
this person that person you gotta watch
your p's and q's for everything because
even wearing this blue t-shirt i'm
offending somebody yeah there'll be a
complaint for sure it's about to say i
find it really offensive if you're
wearing a blizzard that's many because
i'm an [ __ ] fan
yeah exactly and i'm all my united fans
will find it attentive
tyson let me talk to you quickly about
uh the fight please everybody pierce i
don't want to please everybody i don't
know about you i don't want to please
everybody i just want to have my honest
opinions let other people have theirs
have a good argument and go and have a
beer what happened to that that used to
be how our democracy and society worked
well things changed when i went 2022
and everything you say gets taken
personal and everyone wants to cancel
you out you know for everything you say
so you just got to watch what you're
saying pierce shut your mouth and that's
not very good when you're um
you know what i'm not going to watch
what i say twice because i don't think
you do either really i think that both
of us i think have the self-confidence
to say you know what stuff this nonsense
uh yeah stuff the fun police the shame
war my great friend used to say uh
because i think it's just so what it
does it removes all the fun out of life
it makes life a very joyous kind of
experience doesn't it
it does when you can't can't speak the
truth and you think what you think it's
um it's become crazy i don't know what's
going on in the world everybody's upset
for something and no matter what you say
can't please everybody but for me the
only person i'm interested in placing is
my wife and i'm struggling with that
most of the time
there was an interesting moment tyson at
the end of your fight when you claimed
you're going to retire
everybody was groaning nobody wanted to
hear that and your wife looked to me
like she was saying no he's not
something like that she certainly gave
an indication that she doesn't think
you're ready to retire yet why would you
retire you walked out in front of nearly
a hundred thousand people at wembley
going crazy you're at the peak of your
powers you knock out this guy with a
ruthless uppercut there are still one or
two massive fights left for you the
winner of the joshua uzik fight
obviously would be a huge one i don't
think you're ready to retire tyson fury
give me the scoop are you gonna now tell
me right now here's morgan uncensored
that actually
you've got more in you
well let me tell you something pierce
morgan uncensored this is the truth the
gospel truth nothing but the truth i'm
done
you know every good dog has its day and
like the great roman leader said
there'll always be somebody else to
fight when is enough enough i'm happy
i'm healthy i've still got my brains i
can still talk i've got a beautiful wife
i've got six kids i've got obtained
belts i've got plenty of money success
fame glory
what what more am i doing it for you
know boxing's a very dangerous sport you
can be taken out with one punch as we've
seen on saturday night and you know only
takes one on lucky blow one on lucky
blue and you may not get up off that
canvas i'm quitting while i'm ahead i'm
undefeated under the second man in
history
to retire undefeated heavyweight
champion i'm very very happy i'm very
contented in the heart with what i've
done what i've achieved it's not about
money for me pierce you know a lot of
people in this world everything's about
money and more money and more money i've
got enough money i've got enough of
everything i need i'm a very simple man
i drive an 07 vw passat
i'm a very normal person i don't need
tons of money to to impress everybody do
you know what i think about you tyson i
actually think
you think you're a simple normal person
i actually think you're one of the most
fascinating people honestly that i've
ever interviewed i think the way your
mind works i think you're quite a
complex thinker you're a deep thinker
you're highly intelligent uh and yet you
do this you know incredibly violent
sport but that's why in a way i do
believe you because i do think you
probably calculated you look at the
greats muhammad ali who go on too long
who do one big fight too many who get
battered and then never recover i can
understand it i can understand why you
may have with your smart mind calculated
it's just not worth it
it's not worth it you know i've got
family to raise i've got kids to i've
got four young kids to raise and two bit
older ones
um i've been away for the last 10 years
on the road
all over the world traveling for boxing
you know when do i get time to be a
father a husband a brother or son i need
this personal time you know the fans
will always want more they always pay
him for more blood but at the end of the
day i don't have anything more to give
i've give everything i've got i've been
a professional 14 years and i've been
boxing over 20 years
i'm all every good dog has to stay in
the sun and my time is to go out on a
high and i always said that i wanted to
walk away on top of the sport and do it
on my terms and i didn't want to be the
person who said well i should have maybe
retired two years ago or whatever i just
wanted to walk out on top go out with a
bang nearly a hundred thousand that
wembley with a knockout performance they
will not forget the gypsy king in a
hurry and for sure have no amount of of
material assets or money will make me
come back out of retirement because i'm
very happy i completely you know what
tyson
i completely respect you and i get your
argument for it i wanted to ask you a
question uh when i did celebrity
apprentices with donald trump i might
ask you a question about donald trump at
a moment because i know you know him but
when i did it with donald trump lennox
lewis was in there with me and lennox
told me when he was the world
heavyweight champion everywhere he used
to go
in america in particular he'd go to a
bar or a club and the biggest guy in the
bar in the club would want to come and
take him on
to prove their point do you get that and
he said he used to take them on very
quickly and i said what happened to them
he went i was a heavyweight champion in
the world what do you think happened to
him do you get that when you go into
pubs and things do people
say um come on then tyson me and you
you know what pierce never i've not got
that persona or aura about me where i
don't think i'm a tough guy i don't walk
around like the big man um i don't think
i've ever been approached in a bar or a
pub coming from a former alcoholic don't
forget i used to go to a lot of bars and
pubs and restaurants
um i've never been in a fight outside
the ring in my whole life i've not got
that um persona of like oh come and take
me on i'm more like a happy-go-lucky
type when you saw when you saw the other
tysons
when you saw the other tyson from your
sport mike tyson having that incident on
a plane where some guy was drunk and
goading him and eventually tyson gave
him a bit of a slap what did you make of
that
well you know mike tyson's a real og and
you can't mess with mike because he just
don't know what he's gonna do but all
the people all the fun police like you
just said before they'll all be on mike
to get him cancelled as well um but how
can you go around prodding a lion with a
stick how long can you prod a guy for
before he does something about it you
know mike's mike mike don't get the name
for the baddest man on the planet for
nothing so he's not the guy you want a
prodigal stick on the back of a plane
until you get chinned and that's exactly
what happened to the guy and then he
wants to cry about it
if he's man enough to prod mike tyson
and touch him and call him names and
abuse him on a plane then man up and
take a punch in the face so what you
should be paying mike now you can say
you've been punched in the face by a
legend and a world everywhere champion
mike tyson tyson if he's not going to be
boxing i'd pay for that myself
if you're not going to be boxing anymore
tyson what's your big ambition what's
your big what's your big game in life
now
the big game in life now pierce is to
get a job next to you interviewing
people and i'm talking my mind get up
and very quickly i'm told you had a chat
with donald trump recently where he said
to you he is going to run again for
president is that true
well i think he'd be running again for
president 100 why not why not
but he told you that last time he told
you that i think he'll get it this
i think he'll i think yeah i
i think he'll get it this time for sure
2024 i think donald trump will be
president united states again
tyson uh
when you say you think he will i'm told
you know he will because he said that to
you is that true
i'm not going to go on and say what he
did and didn't say in a private
conversation
but let me just say i think he becomes
president again in the next election
that's all for us this week whatever
you're up to this weekend remember make
sure it's uncensored
[Music]
[Music]
i'm tony dunn and this is talk tv the
most memorable moment in my career
without sounding completely conceited it
has to be interviewing president trump
in the open office in the white house
particularly the little red button he
had on his desk i had no idea what he
did is he went to like one of the more
mobile launch a nuclear strike on north
korea or open up a shark pit that i've
been falling to
turn out he pressed it right at the end
of the interview and then walked a
butler with a tray and carried out
here's the diet coke
[Music]
talk tv news at nine
good evening i'm zoro suleiman
three-time wimbledon champion boris
becker has been jailed for two and a
half years for breaking the terms of his
bankruptcy earlier this month he was
found guilty of hiding millions of
pounds worth of assets including two
wimbledon trophies
neil parish the tory mp who allegedly
watched porn in the house of commons
says he opened a file by mistake the mp
for tiverton and honeton in devon faces
a parliamentary investigation and said
he would step down if guilty
a british fighter captured in ukraine
has been paraded on russian state tv
andrew hill is now the third briton to
have been shown on screen and said he
had been shot and can be seen in
pictures with his arm in a sling and
bandages on his head that's all for now
we'll have more after the talk
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you